as you all know don't memorize is now a
part of the sri chat in a group of
educational institutions
and we all know that the sri chat group
has generated thousands of ranks for
various exams over the past 37 years we
are now proud to announce that we are
bringing the same legacy to you through
our learning centers these will be
one-of-a-kind learning centers that will
help you master cbsc school level
concepts as well as test prep exams
these hybrid learning centers combine
our decades of classroom experience
innovation ready technology and a legacy
of producing a league of toppers we are
going to come out with many centers all
across india and will be starting out at
the city of patna we are also hosting
patna's largest career counselling
seminar on the 6th of august at bapu
sabbagar 3 pm onwards to register for
the seminar and to know more about our
learning centers click on the links in
the description below